مدينه شاور ومدن الباكستانيه الاخرى على
مدار الاشهر والاورام الماضيه تفجيرات
وهجمات عشرات القتلى والمصابين في مارس
دار الماضي قتل 56 شخصا على الاقل في هجوم
الانتحاري استهدف مسجدا شيعيا في مدينه
بيشاور شمال غربيه باكستان واتبنه تنظيم
الدوله وفي اكتوبر تشرين الاول عام 2020
قتل تسعه طلاب واصيب نحو 120 اثرا انفجار
عبوه ناسفه داخل مدرسه لتحفيظ القران في
مدينه البشاور ولم تعلم اي جهه مسؤوليتها
لكن شهر يوليو عام 2018
شهد التفجيرا الذي يوصف بالاكثر دمويه في
باكستان وقتل فيه نحو 130 شخصا جرى تفجيرا
استهدف تجمعها انتخابيه في اقليم بلوشستان
جنوب غربيه باكستان انه تنظيم الدوله
وفي العاميه 2017 قتل 25 شخصا بينهم رجال
الشرطه واصيب عشرات في سوق للخضر بمدينه
لاهور في اقليم البونجاب شرق باكستان جراء
تفجير اعلنت حركه طالبان باكستان
مسؤوليتها عنها